[ Applause ]
Diane Greene: Thank you so much, and welcome!
This is just an incredibly exciting event
for all of us in Google Cloud, for all of
us at Google, I would say.
You know, the guy that was mic'ing me was
telling me that there was a queue around the
block, that we had a blockbuster, and I'm
sorry for the queue, but, you know, we're
pretty happy to have all of you here to be
at capacity at 10,000, all the people live-streaming.
I really regret the live-streamers couldn't
see the surround on that amazing animation
that we just showed.
You know, Google -- I mean, cloud, cloud,
does anybody not agree it's the biggest thing
going on in I.T.
right now?
[ Applause ]
Diane Greene: Yeah.
Whoo!
And Google Cloud -- I mean, the adoption of
cloud in general, I believe it must be accelerating.
I know at Google Cloud this year we've seen
unbelievable acceleration.
What's that?
Okay.
And the quality of our customer conversations
are really changing.
We -- you know, for a while it was more "let's
use BigQuery.
Let's do our data analytics.
Let's do our machine learning project."
But just two weeks ago, I met with five customers
over the course of the week, and three of
them said, "Hey, I want to do a full lift
and shift.
I just want to move everything to the cloud."
And it was only last September that we actually
started calling ourselves "Google Cloud."
All that we do from the infrastructure to
the workplace collaboration, productivity,
and even the mobile devices in the enterprise.
It's been a remarkable year.
I mean, our engineers have done over 500 releases.
These are releases to get functionality to
our customers, these are new, innovations.
These are inventions, and just ongoing improvement
in all that we do: Security, reliability,
efficiencies.
Cloud is just an incredibly cool place to
be working right now.
It's basically revolutionizing -- it's sort
of where a lot of the revolution, the digital
revolution for every industry is going on.
In financial services, you know, tremendous
efficiencies on how data is processed or how
the banks can talk directly to their customers.
In health, we're seeing a revolution in diagnosis,
in predicting patient outcomes.
In retail, particularly exciting area, taking
billions of dollars out as we revolutionize
the store of the future.
Media, something Google is particularly well
situated to do.
And energy, manufacturing, optimizing, reducing
the energy usage, making the factories -- making
the factories, the manufacturing, more efficient.
It's incredibly exciting to be part of this.
We have such interesting customers.
We have a customer, Planet Labs, that is taking
pictures of the entire Earth every three hours
and that's going on Google Cloud.
I think the cloud, you know, it's no longer
sort of a utility for surplus peak capacity.
It's no longer a place just to store things.
You know, it's start-ups, it's where they
start but it's not solely for a start-up to
figure out what demand they're going to have
before they spend any money.
Workplace productivity has really moved beyond
sending files around via email.
And the cloud is really what gives -- what's
giving -- increasingly giving customers their
competitive advantage.
And what's important there?
Well, paramount is security.
From the board level on down, nobody -- you
know, everybody really cares about security.
And I'll say a little more about security
at scale in a little bit.
It's about cost, performance, effectivity,
the flexible costs, the lock-in, and it's
about reliability, and I'm just -- because
of all the interest in reliability recently,
I'm just going to say a few words.
You know, you take Google Search.
It was designed -- it runs -- as you see when
you do a search, it runs at five-ninths of
availability.
That's 99.999% up-time.
And we're -- our cloud, that's how we designed
our cloud and we're making it really easy
for our customers to design and deploy for
that kind of reliability.
Distributed, no single point of failure.
And I'm really proud.
I just learned yesterday that we were recognized
as being -- having the highest availability
of any cloud over the course of 2016.
[ Applause ]
Diane Greene: Thank you.
I think 2017 will be promising too, you know.
[ Laughter ]
Diane Greene: We're putting a lot of effort
across the board, across our entire systems,
with the unbelievably excellent engineers
we have, to keep giving you more nines.
What else?
Well, the world, customers, are getting increasingly
focused on data.
You want the world's best data analytics,
the world's best machine learning.
This is definitely a Google strength.
And then finally, workplace culture.
You know, really it's about realtime collaboration.
It's about finding ways to get the bureaucracy
out of a company because everybody's got to
move fast now, and we have the technology
tools to do that.
So over the next three days, you're going
to hear from our engineers.
They're going to tell you about our products.
They're going to give you our roadmaps.
You're going to see lots of demos.
Our customer-facing people will help you navigate
Google Cloud.
And you're also, in this keynote, going to
hear from our customers.
Everybody at Google Cloud is so incredibly
proud of the customers that we have here today
that we've been working with over the course
of the year.
Six customers and a major partner.
So now I just want to pause.
I'm wearing my red ribbon.
I want to acknowledge that it's International
Women's Day today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Diane Greene: Wow!
I have to say that response is pretty exciting.
You know, this industry, I think I've been
incredibly fortunate, but it was sort of an
industry where I -- you know, I was lucky
and I kind of was -- chose to be kind of oblivious
to what was going on, and now we're in an
environment where women are just increasingly
having a huge impact and adding a lot of value
to our industry, and women are celebrated
if they raise their hand and they say, "hey,
you're missing my value.
You're not recognizing what I'm doing."
And at Google, we strive at Google Cloud to
have an environment where no one needs to
raise their hand, but no matter what, it's
completely safe to do that.
You know, I really look forward to the day
when this audience is maybe 50% women.
It's more fun to have diversity.
So shifting gears, now I want to bring on
our next keynote speaker.
It's my phenomenal privilege to introduce
our incredibly smart, compassionate, and just
great leader, Sundar Pichai.
[ Applause ]
Sundar Pichai: Thank you.
This is a big crowd.
I've done many I/O presentations here, and
it feels like a bigger crowd than Google I/O.
So thank you all for joining today.
It's great to be here.
Google is founded on a mission to organize
the world's information and make it universally
accessible and useful.
For many years, we've had the privilege to
create products that have served billions
of consumers across the world.
To do that, we've had to engage pretty much
every branch of computer science.
And we've had breakthroughs along the way.
It has led us to breakthroughs in cloud computing
technology, collaboration software, and analytics,
things which are now transforming businesses
everywhere.
So with Google Cloud, now we offer businesses,
Google-quality computing, security, and business
tools.
And it is an extraordinary big bet for us,
both as a platform internally for our own
innovation but also as a way of bringing our
infrastructure to serve the needs of businesses
across the world.
Our customers and partners will see many ways
to leverage all of Google, be it Google Maps,
Android, YouTube, our devices ecosystem.
And we'll deliver it over the most efficient,
high-performing, and secure core computing
resources.
For over 15 years, we have also been investing
in machine learning and AI.
And as businesses increasingly shift online
and create more information, they can leverage
these AI and machine learning tools to understand
the information and build better products
that delight more customers.
Above all, we are excited to see what you
all will create with our products and services.
When we ship things on the consumer side,
we always get surprised in how they use our
technology in a thousand unexpected ways.
It makes us better as a company.
With Google Cloud, we hope to have the same
journey.
We hope to grow and learn alongside you.
Partners already have pushed us to add more
ways to collaborate beyond video conferencing.
They've exposed us to more real-world scaling
needs.
For example, the demand that retailers like
Home Depot get on Black Friday.
They've shown us exciting new use cases for
Google products.
You will see what eBay has done with Google
Home as an example.
In many ways, to me Google Cloud is a natural
extension of our mission to make information
accessible and useful.
We are just doing it for businesses.
It means increasing the availability and lowering
the cost of data storage and computing resources.
It means making it easier for businesses to
understand and act on critical information.
That's what G Suite does.
G Suite enhances information sharing and collaboration.
Machine learning finds previously hidden patterns
in data, new information which helps businesses
improve their products and better serve their
customers.
So I'm really excited about the progress here,
and I can't wait to see what you all build
next.
So without further delay, I'm going to invite
Diane back on to the stage.
She joined us in late 2015 and the business
has grown dramatically for us under her leadership.
And given that it's International Women's
Day, it's also a pleasure to welcome back
on stage a trailblazer for women in technology.
So let's have Diane back to share more about
how Google Cloud is helping all of you.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Diane Greene: Thank you so much, Sundar.
We really are One Google.
And at Cloud, you know, one of the reasons
I joined, we're leveraging almost two decades
of innovation and technology, really built
for the kind of enterprises we have today
or we're starting to have.
I want to just kind of underscore or say a
few words about our infrastructure.
We don't really normally give out many numbers,
and I'm not going to necessarily break that
policy.
But I am going to tell you some interesting
nuggets, okay?
We have possibly the world's biggest, most
powerful, secure network.
Tomorrow Urs Holzle, who is employee number
eight, behind our data centers and infrastructure
is going to go into this more and tell you
about what we're doing and where we're going.
But today what I'm going to tell you about
is just the kind of the scale of our infrastructure.
If you took not even our largest data center
and stacked all the servers one after another,
it would be higher than more than 5,000 feet
above Mount Everest.
Okay?
I was just going to say above Mount Everest,
but the person that calculated this said no,
no, add the 5,000 feet.
[ Laughter ]
Just one building in our South Carolina campus
is bigger than Stanford's Arrillaga football
stadium.
We have a new complex in the Netherlands.
It's got over 10,000 miles of cable.
That's enough to go from here to Tokyo and
back.
And then one of the things we're all just
very proud of at Google is we've been focused
on being carbon neutral from the beginning.
You know, compute takes a lot of power.
Some days we will be as efficient as our brains,
but it does take a lot of power.
Google is the largest purchaser of renewable
energy.
That's wind farms.
That's solar.
In fact, our purchases are larger than the
next three or four purchasers combined.
[ Applause ]
So why did I tell you about that scale?
Well, I want to give you some examples of
why it matters.
Just two customers, you couldn't have failed
to notice that Niantic Labs launched Pokemon
Go earlier this year.
And just six days after they released, they
kind of eclipsed their most optimistic three-month
predictions.
Their queries increased fifty-fold.
So they were running on Google Cloud.
And our site reliability engineers were with
them 24 hours a day, seven days a week making
this thing go flawlessly.
They were there around the clock.
In fact, it's when we realized we needed the
same kind of functionality for our customers.
Pokemon Go last week at the World Congress
announced -- Niantic announced they had 88
billion Pokemon caught.
Painless scaling on Google Cloud.
The other example is an enterprise customer,
very innovative retailer, Home Depot.
They're now running on Google Cloud.
And we got them through Black Friday.
It was the most painless Black Friday ever.
And they will be here later today to talk
about it.
Also with that scale comes the need for phenomenal
security.
And I'm just going to go into that a little.
This shows sort of the layers of security.
And you can see there's many gaps between
the networks, the servers and the software.
So we built our own chips in the network and
the computing devices.
We have to look at every single endpoint.
We actually have over 700 people just full-time
worrying about security, watching the networks,
securing Google Cloud.
And if you add a Chromebook, which diskless
Chrome -- doesn't store, you get an added
layer of security endpoint.
I personally only use a Chromebook.
By the way, Chromebooks last year outsold
Mac OS in the Macs in the United States.
And something we're really proud of is what
we're doing for education.
Over 20 million Chromebooks used by students
in schools worldwide and growing.
[ Applause ]
So cloud is just a transformational technology.
It's changing how people architect their information,
use their data.
It's changing how they work with their customers,
how they work together.
You know, in effect, our companies are becoming
virtualized.
We're operating both in the physical world
and the virtual, and there's many things you
can do in the virtual world more powerfully
than you can in the physical, particularly
as we all start taking advantage of machine
learning.
You know, I really believe that the cloud
with the best technology is the best cloud.
It gives you a competitive edge.
And you want to be on a cloud that's going
to keep you on the edge of -- technology is
moving so fast, and you want to maintain that
competitive advantage.
But all this technology needs phenomenal customer
focus.
We've really doubled down on our customer-facing
part of Google.
And I'm super -- you know, as I said, super
proud today to give you those proof points,
to have our customers here to tell you about
that, customers and partners.
Just to give you a preview, we've got Disney
here.
We've got our partner SAP.
We've got Colgate-Palmolive.
We've got verizon.
We've got Home Depot.
And we've got HSBC, one of the world's largest
banks.
And then we'll close out with eBay with a
pretty wonderful demo.
So I'm going to begin by bringing out one
of the most loved brands in the industry.
Disney was here last year, and they were just
dabbling in the cloud, just starting to do
some things.
And they actually got more done than they
expected.
They're ahead of schedule.
They're all in, lift and shift.
And then they have aspirations for even bolder
things we will do together.
So I thought it would be very interesting
to start out with the CTO and SVP of Disney
Consumer Products and Interactive Media, Mike
White.
Please welcome him to the stage.
[ Applause ]
Thanks so much.
Okay.
Yeah, we have chairs.
I was worried.
I was wondering where they were.
It's so great to have you back, Mike.
Thanks so much.
Mike White: Thank you.
Diane Greene: We just started talking about
moving Disney Interactive and Consumer Products
to the cloud.
And now you are taking a cloud-first approach.
Can we get an update?
Mike White: For sure.
First off, we really looked at moving to the
cloud as a way to transform the way we develop
software.
And I can tell you it has been really transformative
from us from a software development perspective.
Currently we have about 500 projects in the
cloud.
That includes everything from customer-facing
or guest-facing products in production we
call it, to dev, to QA, to our R&D environments.
And also all of our data suites are running
on BigQuery.
We started with a cloud-first approach for
all new applications since the last time we
talked.
And we've been -- had the luxury of actually
being able to rearchitect a lot of our legacy
systems for the cloud.
As you mentioned, we are ahead of schedule.
That's really a testament to -- you said the
word "partnership" earlier.
It truly is a partnership we developed with
Google that has been really helpful for us.
So thank you for that.
Diane Greene: Oh, you're welcome.
I think our teams just really clicked and
really just collaborated phenomenally to bring
your vision to life.
Mike White: Yeah, for sure.
I think it was really great talking developers
to developers and making developers come in
first for this.
But what was really interesting was within
our division, we have different application
characteristics.
So we have some really top-ranking games.
We have kids chat app.
We have several Disney sites that are all
running out of Google Cloud.
And that's both internationally and domestically.
But what's that really done for us -- and
I talked a little bit about being transformative
from the software development side, it's really
been able to free up our developers and our
resources.
And the way we look at our developers is they
are technologists that are storytellers.
For us, we use technology in service of the
story.
That's what we do at Disney.
That's been our legacy since Walt.
So we've really been able to focus on telling
great stories.
And with that, we've been really taking a
machine learning mindset as we're on our road
to AI.
And so if you think about character development,
an extension of characters, and really getting
closer to the characters, that's really where
we want to play.
Really with this first lens of machine learning,
I think in the short-term, we're really looking
at how that will impact retail, which we're
really excited about.
Diane Greene: It sounds like magic helping
magic.
Do you mean just for your operations you're
doing this, or is it really touching the customer?
Mike White: It is both.
So for sure we're leveraging things like image
recognition technology for some back-end services.
But we also have 8,000 characters within Marvel.
And you can imagine all the images that come
with that.
We're also looking at ways to really strengthen
the connection of our consumers through optimization,
personalization and really enhanced experiences.
So those are customer facing and back-end
as well.
We look at that as kind of a symbiotic relationship.
Diane Greene: You know, I just love your mission
at Disney, to bring this magic, you know,
to the daily lives of people and your fans
around the world.
It's so great to support that.
Mike White: Yeah, I mean, that's what gets
us up in the morning; right?
Our companies, stories, characters mean so
much to so many people.
I mean, for everyone in the audience, I can
imagine that you have a favorite character
that's Disney or Pixar or Marvel or Star Wars.
And with that, maybe you have multiple, which
is great.
And so that's really what we do.
We use technology to empower and really create
the magic and we're really excited with the
potential of machine learning and AI what
that can do for us.
So thank you.
Diane Greene: Thank you, Mike.
I can't wait to see where we are next year.
Thanks so much.
Mike White: Thanks so much.
Diane Greene: Great having you here.
Mike White: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Diane Greene: You know, it's pretty exciting
for us to see this full lift and shift happening
from just sort of an initial fairly small
engagement, sort of what I was describing
earlier, and then next year doing even cooler
things with our commitment to really just
all-out partnering with our customers.
Now -- you know, actually, I just want to
mention that in 1955, the average age of a
company was about 75 years, and now in this
year, the average age of a company is only
about 17 years.
But all of our customers and partners that
are here today are -- have been around much
longer than that and are beating the odds.
Even eBay, you know, at 22 years.
I don't mean "even eBay."
I mean even our youngest has been longer.
I love to partner.
I love to work with a community of technology
companies.
And, you know, we can build on their offerings,
they can build on ours, and it's just terrific
for the customers.
Customers first, always; then our partners.
We've been working with SAP for, you know
-- over the course of the last year, and the
more we've been working together, the more
we see that we can do.
I was recently in Germany.
It was very exciting to be, you know, at this
-- you know, the world's biggest ERP firm,
a company that when I started working in the
I.T.
industry at Sybase, prepublic, you know, they
were already, you know, such an impressive
company.
So today, I am really thrilled to welcome
to the stage Google Cloud's latest major strategic
partner, Bernd Leukert, head of technology
and innovation and executive -- member of
the Executive Board at SAP.
[ Applause ]
Diane Greene: Hi, Bernd.
Bernd Leukert: Thank you, Diane.
Diane Greene: Oh, thank you.
Bernd Leukert: And a warm welcome to the Google
Cloud attendees, as well, from my side.
I mean, you said it already.
Representing here SAP as a company which now
for almost 45 years is enabling companies
to succeed across 25 industries across 11
lines of business with our cloud and in historical
times as well our on-premise products.
Diane Greene: Yes.
Bernd Leukert: And, I mean, you refer to the
former times.
I still remember joining SAP when mainframe
computing --
Diane Greene: Yeah.
Sara Robinson: -- was the flagship.
We had R/2 at that point in time, and since
that time we have led many technology waves
and helped our customers to succeed going
forward.
And as you saw, that technology passion -- I
liked what you said --
[ Laughter ]
Bernd Leukert: -- and our focus on customers
has rewarded us, that we are able to serve
now more than 345,000 customers -- I have
to say "enterprise customers" -- creating
products, and used by millions of people and
decision-makers day in and day out.
And one of our most important innovations
just recently is, of course, a growth engine
for us, the last couple of days.
This is our flagship product, SAP HANA.
SAP HANA is our in-memory data and analytics
platform, and in the meantime, as well, used
by more than 14,000 customers.
And these customers implement scenarios that
leverage HANA's advanced analytical processing.
They use spatial graphs, streaming data, text
analysis, as well as predictive capabilities,
and to turn machine learning inside into real
intelligence and then followed into action.
Of course, as well, use that platform for
our traditional transactional business.
Diane Greene: You know, it's just such an
impressive story.
Hasso Plattner, you know, and you and how
you've been so agile and keep reinventing
SAP and, you know, I first was aware of my
Hasso because my sailboat racing.
He has very good taste in boats.
But he's also been great for design thinking
you've led in the mainframe, in the client
server, and now making a core part of your
business the cloud.
Bernd Leukert: And I mean Hasso was basically
one of our founders and is still the technology
advisor, and we have now SAP, the goal these
days, to become the cloud company powered
by HANA, but now we are ready to take things
a step further, and today we are delighted
to announce here in San Francisco the general
availability of SAP HANA on Google Cloud Platform.
Of course --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Bernd Leukert: Of course if anybody questions,
with full support from our SAP's existing
support contracts, no doubt about that.
And we will offer enterprises the world's
leading best network, the fastest service,
and the best enterprise data platform for
mission-critical applications analytics in
one stop.
And for the developers and the engineers in
the audience, I'm also pleased to announce
that the developer edition for SAP HANA -- we
call it HANA Express -- is also being offered
in Google Cloud Launcher, which is Google's
marketplace for enterprise-related partner
applications.
And with just a laptop, it's going to be easy
to build SAP software applications capable
of instantly working with the largest possible
suite of products, accessing data in the on-prem
and in the cloud world.
And obviously this is great news for our corporate
software developers -- and I mean our joint
corporate software developers -- looking to
build new products on existing data and applications.
Diane Greene: Thank you.
Bernd Leukert: And our cloud partnership story,
with you, with Google, does not stop here.
This is just the starting point.
Diane Greene: That's right.
Bernd Leukert: We are working on running the
SAP Cloud Platform, and specifically our cloud
foundry-based platform as a service framework
with a host of business and integration service
as well on the Google Cloud Platform.
And we recognize Google definitely as a frontrunner,
as a frontrunner in technologies and specifically
in topics like containerization, in scalable
data processing which are featured prominently
here at the Google NEXT conference.
And our SAP Cloud Platform and big data teams
will work very closely on -- with your teams
--
Diane Greene: Yes.
Bernd Leukert: -- on making technologies such
as Kubernetes, such as Spanner, work for scaling
enterprise workloads, and I see a tremendous
opportunity, moving forward from that point,
for our customers to build these scalable
enterprise applications using these endless
combinations of services of APIs exposed on
the Google Cloud Platform but as well on the
SAP Cloud Platform.
And we will have that offer together for you,
for our customers.
Diane Greene: Yes.
Bernd Leukert: And lastly, our joint memorandum
of understanding on machine learning co-development
is just the starting point.
It's just the starting point and you can expect
to hear more from the two of us -- or from
our companies -- and our next big milestone
is the SAP SAPPHIRE event, which is SAP's
Google NEXT in May in Orlando.
Diane Greene: You know, this is just a tremendously
important partnership to us here at Google,
and our commitment really is to SAP and your
thousands of customers.
As another -- yet another, but a really big
deal, element of our partnership with SAP
and -- between SAP and Google Cloud, we're
collaborating to develop leading industry
governance, risk and compliance.
We want a solution for the public cloud.
And what that means is it's going to enable
SAP to be a data custodian of the customer's
data that's stored in GCP.
It's increasingly important for enterprises,
you know, customers moving from on-prem to
the cloud, to retain their insight, their
control, while still benefiting, you know,
from the agility, the scale, the presence
of a public cloud, and we see this joint solution
as the basis for a new way to approach compliance
and governance in public cloud environments.
Bernd Leukert: I completely agree, Diane.
And being with Google Cloud ensures, from
my perspective, deployment to the greatest
number of markets and enterprise and visions,
and our strategic intent is to work on extending
GCP's robust set of existing capabilities,
so jointly develop solutions that bring global
visibility, access control -- which our customers
ask for --
Diane Greene: That's right.
Bernd Leukert: -- to our customers for improved
risk and compliance management.
And to serve as a data custodian, we feel
honored.
And this is a first step.
We analyzed GCP's audit logs to assure appropriate
visibility and control, but, again, not for
us.
Again, for our customers.
And ultimately work towards approving access
control requests and even -- you mentioned
security before -- encryption key management
on service provider access to the customer's
data.
Diane Greene: You know, I really think this
partnership is going to improve compliance
and risk and, you know, really ease the hassle
that thousands of companies, millions of customers,
are facing.
You know, we really see opportunities also
for more of the machine learning on SAP's
data and applications, getting our -- you
know, the enterprises just more value and
insight from the data they already have, you
know, building these new applications.
This is -- and that's why we're announcing
these plans to work jointly on our new machine
learning.
We're also really interested in tighter integrations
with G Suite --
Is this your part?
Bernd Leukert: No.
Diane Greene: Okay.
-- with G Suite as collaborative tools, and
-- anyhow, we actually -- G Suite, I'll just
say, is a platform also with open APIs, and
so we are integrating G Suite with the SAP
applications.
I think that's going to be super exciting
for people.
You know, really increase customer satisfaction.
And just to underscore that, we have a joint
customer, just a wonderful person, and from
a company that's actually 211 years old, I'm
really pleased to welcome Mike Crowe, the
chief information officer from Colgate-Palmolive,
if he can join us on stage.
[ Applause ]
Bernd Leukert: By the way, a long-lasting
friend of mine.
Diane Greene: Hi, Mike.
Thank you.
Mike Crowe: Good morning.
Bernd Leukert: Good to see you.
Diane Greene: Great to have you here, Mike.
Please, why don't you just tell us a little
bit about Colgate-Palmolive and your partnerships
with both of us.
Mike Crowe: Oh, sure.
So, first of all, thanks for having me.
I'm happy to be here.
Colgate is a leading global consumer products
company, selling our products in 223 countries
around the world.
Our 38,000 Colgate people focus on four core
categories: oral care, personal care, home
care, and pet nutrition.
Likewise, we have a very focused I.T.
strategy which at its core relies on a small
number of strategic partnerships.
We chose SAP 23 years ago, and Google Cloud
just last year, for very much the same reasons.
You're both highly innovative and you both
have a willingness to partner with us.
And we see tremendous value from implementing
your technology.
We've, of course, been innovating with SAP
for years on business processes and we're
already starting to see the benefit of Google's
collaboration suite of applications.
Diane Greene: So Mike, I mean, you were one
of the first potential customers I met when
I joined Google, and now you've implemented
G Suite.
Can you tell us a little bit about it?
Mike Crowe: Sure.
So we started our project in May of last year
and we were very encouraged by the positive
email responses we received from our employees
as we announced that we were Going Google.
Still, we knew that it would be a major change
management effort to go to a new collaboration
platform, so Diane, we worked with your team
as well as our implementation partner, SADA
Systems, to lay out a phased approach for
implementation, and in just three months we
were able to launch for our global I.T.
organization all around the world.
We learned from that and then we leveraged
that excitement that our employees had shown
to recruit a few thousand volunteers to be
early adopters.
And within that set, we had about 900 Google
guides who were to be the champions on the
ground as we implemented and to be the trainers
as we rolled out.
And all of that set us up very nicely for
our final implementation, which was in one
weekend in November we took more than 20,000
users live.
So all told, more than 28,000 users in six
months.
Diane Greene: Yeah, Mike.
I mean, it's just phenomenal to successfully
move 23,000 people over the weekend, and I
can't tell you how much I enjoyed the little
video you sent me to educate your company
where you're sitting there talking to Mr.
C, a cartoon character.
What have you seen since you launched?
Mike Crowe: Well, in just a little over three
months, we see that people are working differently.
Sure, everybody is using mail and calendar,
but the usage of the other tools is quite
impressive.
90% of our users are active on Google Drive,
and in February alone, we had more than 57,000
hours of video Hangouts.
You know, allowing our user base to connect
more easily both while in the office as well
as on mobile devices while outside the office.
And this is critically important for us as
our Colgate teams around the world work more
and more together from different locations.
And then finally, I'm seeing a faster uptake
in the productivity suites, in docs and sheets
and slides as well.
Faster than I had expected.
Bernd Leukert: So Mike, I still remember when
you asked me last summer, "How is your relationship
to Google?"
And I was thinking we have conversation, now
he is asking me, he knows me now for more
than two decades, but now we are here together.
I think it's pretty amazing.
But I have to ask you: Now we have made the
first step, but what excites you going forward?
What should the two of us deliver to you going
forward?
Mike Crowe: Well, you know, first I'm very
excited about the Google/SAP partnership,
about the announcements that have been made
here today, and about the possibilities that
the combined strengths of these two great
companies bring out.
I think it makes perfect sense, it's a perfect
fit, to combine SAP's business -- enterprise
business application expertise with Google's
expertise on Infrastructure-as-a-Service running
in the Google Cloud platform.
Bernd, you and I have been talking about incorporating
machine learning into a broad array of the
SAP business processes for some time, so excited
about that as well.
Bernd Leukert: Yes.
Mike Crowe: And then one more example, as
you know, we're users of SAP's Digital Boardroom,
a co-innovation project between us and SAP
which allows us to review the state of the
business at any time using the latest data,
and we're already working on incorporating
Google slides into that application as well.
So in summary, I think the possibilities are
going to be numerous for us.
Diane Greene: This has been really terrific
for us.
We've really enjoyed working with both of
you.
It's great for Google Cloud, it's great for
you guys, and we're really looking forward
to see what we're all going to do next.
Thank you so much, both of you.
Bernd Leukert: Thanks for having us here,
Diane.
Diane Greene: Yeah.
All right.
Bernd Leukert: Thanks a lot.
Diane Greene: Thanks, guys, that was great.
Mike Crowe: Thanks.
Diane Greene: As Mike was saying, G Suite
is this fantastic collaboration suite.
It's really transforming the culture and the
productivity at Colgate.
One thing also that I'll just add about G
Suite that we hear in every customer that
deploys is the young people so rejoice when
G Suite gets rolled out.
And one of our bigger customers, PwC, actually
did a poll of their employee base.
And the number one valued thing from particularly
their young employees was their collaboration
and productivity tool.
It's so important to them.
Okay.
So for our next guest, I'm really excited
to bring out a premiere technology company,
Verizon.
They have got 114 million retail customers.
We've been working closely with Verizon for
a year now, not simply -- and we've been working
with them on workplace productivity.
It's been a long project.
It's been a challenging project.
And that's -- I really wanted to talk about
that here.
It's gone really well, great outcome.
And here to talk about it coming on stage
let me welcome Alin D'Silva who is the vice
president for digital workplace at Verizon.
[ Applause ]
Hi, Alin.
Thanks so much for coming.
Great to see you.
Alin D'Silva: Good morning, everyone.
At Verizon, we believe deeply in our brand
statement which says, "Better Matters."
And we believe better matters not just for
our customers but our employees as well.
We are keenly aware of the need to move faster,
collaborate more effectively, have flexibility
in how they work, when and where.
And it's really a commitment we've made to
a much more modern and progressive work environment.
And we're delighted that G Suite is going
to be a big part of that transformation.
Diane Greene: So are we.
We are delighted, too, Alin.
You know, starting in just a few weeks, I
understand you're going to start moving 150,000
Verizon workers over to the GC platform.
But we both know it didn't happen that quickly,
that you started down this path more than
a year ago.
And I would just like to know, what were you
looking for?
Alin D'Silva: Yeah.
So a little over a year ago we formed a group
that was really focused on raising the bar
in productivity through collaboration and
employee engagement.
And we've done a lot in that short period
of time.
We fostered collaboration by rolling out activity-based
workplaces.
We rolled out unified communications globally.
And we made improvements to our mobile options.
We realized we were really missing some key
features, things like realtime collaboration
and other modern features that you see in
these productivity suites.
So we did a comprehensive trial of G Suite,
and our employees really loved it.
They loved the simplicity and intuitiveness
of the product, the ease of use.
The realtime collaboration really blew them
away.
You know, it worked well on desktops.
What they were really surprised by was how
well it worked on mobile devices.
And, you know, the simplicity of the solution
actually helped us secure the platform in
a much more straightforward way.
And then I would say the last thing is that
we realized that actually a number of our
employees at Verizon, specifically at companies
like AOL and Telogis were already on G Suite.
And so for us that's how we came about to
make the decision.
We realized we had to escape to where the
puck is going because in terms of talent,
we knew, you know, as the years passed, the
talent that comes into the company is going
to expect a product like this.
And so we had that in mind as we made our
decisioning.
Diane Greene: Thank you.
You know, Alin, a lot of the time, changes
-- change can be pretty hard no matter how
good the technology is.
And did you have resistance in going to the
cloud?
And what did you do about that, if you did
have that resistance?
Alin D'Silva: Sure, we had a fair amount of
resistance.
But it is really a matter of addressing the
fundamental perceptions of what it takes to
go to the cloud.
So what we did is we cracked open the door.
We asked everyone to sort of keep an open
mind.
And then over several months, you know, we
got really deep on a number of topics like
security, operations, user experience, regulation,
and compliance matters.
And we also looked closely at ROI, of course.
And in going through the trial, in talking
to you, in talking to your partners, in talking
to your customers, we realized that really
it was the right decision for us.
The Google team was really fantastic to work
with.
Eric Geithner, if you're out there, kudos
to you.
But they answered all of our questions.
You know, they got us really comfortable with
the decision that we needed to make.
Diane Greene: Thanks for that shout-out to
Eric.
Alin, do you have any advice for anyone in
the audience that's looking at making a similar
transformation that you've gone through at
Verizon?
Alin D'Silva: Absolutely.
So, first of all, you've got to bring along
all the stakeholders that are going to be
key in the decision-making that you're going
to make.
So bring along your CISO and legal teams for
starters for sure because they need to go
on this journey with everyone.
They have got to understand what it's going
to take and get comfortable with it.
The other thing we found is we learned a lot
from customers of Google and G Suite and from
partners.
So I would say definitely take advantage of
that.
Remember that this is, like, partly -- I mean,
it's a technology transformation, but it's
really about change and driving change in
the organization.
So you've really got to give thought to how
you're going to drive change management around
this.
And I would say, like, you know, if your mission
is to go transform the company, then you really
have to have meaningful change.
Otherwise, like, where's the transformation?
Diane Greene: Right.
So what has the reception been like since
you announced this move to G Suite?
Alin D'Silva: The reception has been pretty
interesting.
So we put out an article on our Internet site
in the middle of January.
And within a couple of days, it got the most
reads for the whole month.
We had hundreds of comments and questions
that were posted.
And, you know, people saw it as a really meaningful
step in the right direction.
These were folks who had experienced G Suite
at other jobs or had used it in their personal
lives.
And they were really comfortable and excited
about the idea that we would go forward in
this direction.
And then there were a number of employees
who, you know, naturally were concerned about
how it was going to change their job.
They were used to doing things a certain way.
And they posted a lot of questions online.
And we went through and answered each and
every one of them.
And that really helped the broader community
understand where we were going.
And that was really important.
We also identified all the early enthusiasts,
the ones -- we call them Google guides, just
like Mike said earlier.
We are going to rope them into early adoption
phases of this so they can get on board and
get ready to support our colleagues when we
bring them overall.
So, you know, it was a great validation.
It was a great early validation that we made
the right choice, and we are really looking
forward to starting the migrations in a few
weeks.
Diane Greene: You know, it's a big step, Alin.
And I really admire the commitment you brought
to bear on this.
We have been working pretty closely.
I know I will be hearing more from you, and
I really look forward to the updates and supporting
you.
Alin D'Silva: Great.
Thanks, Diane.
Diane Greene: Thank you.
Thanks so much.
Bye-bye.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, G Suite, you know, is built for the
cloud, integrated, works seamlessly.
It's really proving its value.
Going back to Google Cloud, once someone decides
to move to Google Cloud, you know, we really
have an incredible commitment to deliver top-quality
customer support.
We don't want any of our customers going down.
You know, we use site reliability engineers
to keep our seven apps that have over a billion
active users available.
And we realized, as I said before, with the
Niantic Pokemon Go launch that our customers
need the same.
We established a new organization called customer
reliability engineering services where those
people work with our customers to make sure
that your services are architected and monitored
and keep full availability.
Now, Google can't scale to do enough customer
reliability engineers for all of our customers.
And so what we've done is we've reached out
to partners, and I'm really excited today
to announce two of our early partners.
We have Pivotal Labs, a premiere consulting
development company leading in agile development,
our first certified CRE partner.
They offer CRE services to our customer.
And then another customer, really a pioneer
in the cloud, they understand the cloud inside
out, that's Rackspace.
And they are our first managed service provider,
and we look forward to doing more and more
with them.
Now somebody that's already taken advantage
of our CRE, Home Depot.
I'm really excited to welcome to the stage
Paul Gaffney, senior vice president at Home
Depot.
[ Applause ]
Hi, Paul.
Thanks so much.
Paul Gaffney: Great to see you.
Diane Greene: So you have got an impressive
history.
Quite an innovative retailer doing extremely
well.
How do you think about technology?
Paul Gaffney: Technology is a really important
thing to us, particularly in this landscape
as consumers' expectations are increasingly
being shaped by the software that they use.
We've got over 2,000 stores in North America
and 400,000 real, live human beings who take
care of our customers.
And that's our heritage, that excellent experience
that you get when you're talking to someone
wearing an orange apron.
And increasingly consumers are expecting that
we do exactly that same thing in software.
So we think about software as an extension
of our overall culture.
Diane Greene: It's sort of your virtual company
running, isn't it?
Paul Gaffney: It is.
Diane Greene: And what have been the proof
points in using the cloud for you?
Paul Gaffney: The important thing about cloud
for us, as we started to get better as a software
engineering organization, we paid attention
to a lot of different things.
One of those things was building cloud-native
apps.
There were a variety of reasons why we focused
on building cloud-native apps.
But we also said, well, we should probably
run them on the cloud if we're going to build
them cloud native.
And cloud plays an important role for us economically.
Cloud economics are a substantial improvement
to our on-premises economics but also thinking
differently about resiliency and availability.
Moving from, I think, what's a classical big
company I.T.
orientation, which is make the infrastructure
robust, to a more modern view that says, just
assume that everything is going to fail.
And that was a big catalyst for us to engineer
our software differently and partner with
you guys on learning what does it mean to
live in a world where you make your stuff
resilient to failure.
Diane Greene: You know, I've come to love
all these days when you have these spike loads.
And you guys recently, you know -- of course,
every year you have Black Friday.
I was just wondering, how did it go for you
guys this year?
Paul Gaffney: I'm glad you love these spike
loads.
[ Laughter ]
And as shareholders --
Diane Greene: I bite my fingernails.
No, not really.
Paul Gaffney: So do we.
As everyone in here is a consumer, I think
you guys all know there are times during the
year when all of us in retail attempt to conspire
to get you to do more shopping than is normal.
But those of you who are in the room who know
that that ends up somewhere, that has to be
processed, one of the fantastic things about
an elastic environment is you don't have to
attempt to provision in advance and pay for
in advance all of that spike.
And if you architect your stuff correctly,
you can scale that out instead of having to
scale it up.
And we were really -- we were really nervous,
not because we weren't prepared.
The team that worked on this does fantastic
prep, and you guys were a great partner.
Diane Greene: Do have great technologists.
Paul Gaffney: I mean, outstanding prep.
But everyone is kind of nervous.
Thankfully our 400,000 folks do such a nice
job each year that more folks do business
with us each year.
So this last Black Friday was an all-time
high for us, and we were running meaningful
portions of our eCommerce infrastructure on
Google infrastructure on Google Cloud for
the first time.
And it was our smoothest performance ever.
Diane Greene: Just tremendous to see.
And it's great to see you using Kubernetes
and containers.
How about your work with big data?
Paul Gaffney: I think, as you know, a very
interesting off-shoot of our partnership on
cloud was thinking about, okay, we're going
to be moving some main line, line of business
workload from on-premises to the cloud.
Should we be doing the same thing with data?
And as the audience might imagine, we've got
a lot of data.
And we replenish those 2,000 stores continuously.
And we have started to move quite a bit of
our data analytics environment from proprietary
on-premises infrastructure onto BigQuery and
other parts.
I think, you know, I'm excited by the technology.
But, frankly, I'm more excited by the investments
you guys are making in talent.
And I'm looking forward to the work we're
going to do on exploring some really interesting
problems where we think that the machines
can help us understand some things perhaps
that the humans find difficult to understand.
Diane Greene: Yeah.
I mean, we're really looking forward to this
ongoing work.
And I can tell you that Fei Fei Li and her
cloud machine learning group are really excited
about what they're going to be able to do
with Home Depot.
Thanks so much, Paul, for being here.
Paul Gaffney: Great pleasure, Diane.
Thank you.
Diane Greene: Okay.
Bye-bye.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
So now we're going to turn and we're going
to talk about security, privacy data analytics
that scale with a big bank.
And here to lead that discussion and tell
you about it, I'm delighted to welcome Tariq
Shaukat, Google Cloud's President for all
customer-facing operations.
[ Applause ]
Tariq Shaukat: Thank you, Diane.
Good morning, everybody.
So you've heard a lot today from our customers,
and you've heard a lot today from Diane and
from Sundar about what our mission is here
at Google Cloud.
But to put it in the terms of what we're looking
to do for customers, we very much view our
mission at Google Cloud and on our customer
team as generating real -- a real step change
in business value for our customers.
That business value happens in a number of
different ways and increasingly in mission-critical
applications.
It happens, first of all, at the cost-savings
level of how do you actually move to a more
flexible environment, how do you move to a
more agile environment, how do you move to
a lower cost environment.
And so that is absolutely one of the major
conversations that we have with our customers.
As you heard Paul talk about and you heard
Mike from Disney talk about, we also are increasingly
seeing the cloud being used as a platform
to drive real tangible revenue growth for
companies, for them to both create new applications
but also critically importantly to understand
their customers better, to get into their
data better, and to really understand how
to become closer to their customers, how to
become more efficient in their operations,
and how to engage their employees better.
So you have the cost-savings piece, and you
have the revenue-generation piece.
But the third part that really has been a
thrilling evolution of the market is how many
companies are really coming to Google Cloud
now and saying, "We need a partnership."
And we need a partnership to help transform
our business, to really help us think about
what is the business model of the future and
how do we take our existing operations and
how do we move that in a both gradual way
and in a step-changed way into the future.
One of the most thrilling partnerships that
we have in this regard is with HSBC.
HSBC challenges us in each and every one of
these areas, on the cost savings, on the revenue
growth, and on the transformation levels every
day.
Now, you may know them as one of the largest
financial institutions in the world.
They have over 150-year history, 4,000 offices
in 70 countries, and over 2 trillion, $2 trillion
of assets on their balance sheet.
Now, to tell you more about this, I'm truly
delighted to welcome to the Google Cloud stage
Darryl West who is the global chief information
officer at HSBC.
And he's going to share his thinking about
the roll of cloud and cloud scale data analytics
and machine learning for the financial services
world.
Darryl?
[ Video ]
Speaker: We are living in a type of rapid
digital change, where the only limits are
the scale of our ideas and degree of identification.
The technology ideas of today will be the
intuitive habits of tomorrow.
Never before has innovation promised so much
touching so many in so many different ways.
Our frontier is financial technology.
It's changing the way we work, make money,
and the way we trust each other.
To succeed, we need to adopt the mindset of
the silicon hubs of the world and create an
incubator of free thinker, thought leaders,
innovators born of collaborative spirit.
All fueled by a belief that technology will
enhance our customers' financial lives to
imagine a future beyond what we already know,
creating a team with the power to transform
the world's leading financial enterprise.
We are technology.
[ Applause ]
Darryl West: Thank you, Tariq.
Good morning, everybody.
It gives me immense pleasure to be able to
be here with you today, particularly on International
Women's Day.
I've been at HSBC now for a couple of years,
and I have the honor and privilege of leading
an awesome I.T.
team that's at the center of an amazing transformation
happening in our organization.
I'm going to talk about our commitment to
cloud, and I'm going to talk about how we're
collaborating and partnering with Google to
make HSBC a simpler, better, and faster organization,
an organization focused on amazing customer
experiences through digital channels and a
company committed to using the latest technology
in data analytics and machine learning to
transform the way we run our business.
Now, I'm sure many of you in the audience
are travelers and I'm sure many of you have
stood in airport walkways and seen the HSBC
advertisements, and they're quite distinctive.
And you've probably asked the question, "Who
are these people?"
Well, who are we?
We're the world's largest international bank.
As Tariq said, we've been around for 150 years.
We're present in 70 countries.
We have 37 million customers.
Customers ranging from individuals to small
businesses, mid-sized corporates, large global
companies, as well as governments as well.
So we have a huge business, a huge global
business.
We're the number one bank in the world for
trade finance and cross-border financing and
we're a significant player in the global foreign
exchange markets.
So given our central position in global finance,
as you can imagine, we are a systemically
important financial institution heavily regulated.
Now, in the banking business, clearly trust
and confidence is a central part of our business.
We have to make sure that our customers feel
confident and trust in us to be the custodians
of their assets.
So, you know, information security, reliability,
and resilience in how we deliver our services
are fundamental to our business.
Now, apart from having the $2.4 trillion of
assets on the balance sheet, we also have
at the core of the company a massive asset
in our data and, you know, what's been happening
in the last two or three years is a massive
growth in the size of our data asset.
So as you can see here, 56 petabytes of data
in 2014.
That's actually doubled.
As of now, sitting here in 2017, over 100
petabytes of data.
And what's happening is our customers are
adopting our digital channels more aggressively.
We're collecting much more data about how
our customers are interacting with us.
And obviously embedded in this data is massive
insights, and what we need to do as a bank
is work with partners to enable us to understand
what's happening with this data, draw out
the insights so we can run a better business,
and create some amazing customer experiences.
Now, our journey in data is very similar to
other companies.
This is no -- this is no different to many
enterprise companies, the history here.
We have lots of good old-fashioned databases.
All of our core systems are running on product
systems that have been around for 20, 30,
even 40 years.
The systems are robust and they're scalable
and they do a great job but they don't have
database structures that actually allow us
to really do the data analytics, the machine
learning that we need to do.
So the history of enterprises like mine is
that we typically did extracts into traditional
data warehousing platforms, which worked well
for many years but of recent times they've
become expensive to run and difficult to use.
So we took the plunge about three years ago
to really embed ourselves into the evolving
Hadoop ecosystem.
And for an organization like mine that has
this traditional history of what we call legacy
platforms, it's been a tough -- it's been
a tough road for us.
All of this has been done on-prem.
We've had to provision large infrastructure,
physical infrastructure, build out data centers,
and hire talented new people that have understanding
of these new technologies.
So we thought about this very carefully in
the last year and we said to ourselves, "Well,
really, we're a bank.
At the core of our business, we're a bank.
But we also have a significant technology
company embedded within the organization."
And the question that I was asking the management
team is, you know, "Do we really want to compete
with the cloud providers and people like Google?
Are we really going to try and do what they
do as well as they do it?"
I think our conclusion was that it was better
for our business if we adopt a cloud-first
strategy.
So we started working with Google about six
months ago now, so it's still early in our
relationship, but we've been working with
them on some of the most important and critical
business problems that we have to solve in
our business.
To give you an idea of what these types of
problems are, so the initial use cases here
are typically characterized by business problems
that have very large data sets and require
very intense computing capability in short
bursts.
Now, the first one on this list is all about
anti-money laundering, so as one of our obligations
of being a bank, we work with the -- with
the governments and the crime agencies to
identify nefarious activity, money laundering
criminal activity.
Now, we have a set of applications that monitor
a huge time series of data, so a massive data
set, billions of transactions, for all of
our customers.
We're running analytics over this huge data
set with great, you know, compute capability
to identify patterns in the data and to bring
out what looks like nefarious activity within
our customer base.
And those patterns that we identify then are
escalated into the agency, so we work with
them to track down the bad guys.
So this is an application that clearly requires
massive data sets, great computing capability,
but also a machine learning capability to
be able to identify the patterns in this huge
-- this huge data set.
The other applications that are mentioned
here in terms of finance and risk, we have
billions of transactions.
Those transactions need to be aggregated so
we can manage our finances and our risk at
a global level.
Our valuation services and our trading business,
as I said, we're a major player in global
financial markets.
We need to be able to run complex multicolor
simulations on a regular basis to be able
to better understand our trading positions
and our risks, so this requires a significant
compute capability.
So we were faced with the question of do we
build out a new data center and put, you know,
thousands of servers and thousands of cores
out there to do this activity or should we
actually work with somebody who does it as
a core business.
And our conclusion was rather than build it
out ourselves, we should be working with,
you know, world-class leaders in this space
and, hence, our work with Google.
Now, all of this doesn't happen by accident
and there are some critical enablers that
have to all be in place to make this work
for organizations like us.
The first couple of boxes here talk about
risk and compliance and information security.
You know, we are a heavily regulated business.
We have to provide very resilient, very safe,
and very performant services to our customers,
and also very agile, because the requirements
of our customers are changing tremendously
quickly.
We also have to respect the data protection
and data residency rules that we have.
In our 70 countries, there are lots of rules
about what data can sit where and what data
can be share, so we have to respect all of
that and we're working closely with our partner
at Google on these -- on this construct.
Information security, as you heard already
this morning, it's a massive issue for everyone.
Particularly for a bank.
We have to keep our data safe from the cybercriminals,
and we're working very well with Google on
solutions in the security space.
Probably the biggest impact, though, or the
biggest enabler for this journey is the -- are
the two boxes in the middle here.
You have to drive a cultural shift in your
business to make this really work.
You have to adopt an agile methodology.
You have to adopt a devops mind-set, and you
need to be able to recruit and retain talented
people that understand how to use these new
technologies and work in this way.
So just a point of note.
We are recruiting.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Darryl West: And we're a great company, just
like Google.
[ Laughter ]
Darryl West: So the other issue here on the
second box here is about integration.
I mentioned the legacy platforms we have.
All of our core data is sitting on these systems
of record.
We have to make sure that we can integrate
all of this technology complexity to work
with the Google platform, the Google Cloud
Platform, so this integration layer is very,
very important.
You've got to get that culture in place, you
have to get the people that understand how
to do it, and you have to build the integration
layer so you'll be able to it all work in
that rapid cycle.
And lastly, of course, data preparation.
You know, we have, like most big enterprises,
a data sprawl.
As I said, we've had a massive growth of data.
But also, you need to invest your time and
effort in your data architecture and making
sure you understand where your crown jewels
are, where the copies are, and get a really
good understanding of the preparation of getting
the data ready to be able to interface effectively
into the cloud partner.
And obviously agreements of legal and commercial
are obviously very important as well.
So in summary, these enablers are fundamental
to us achieving our goals at HSBC and we are
working in very collaborative and partnership
mode with Google to get these enablers in
place to run a better business.
[ Applause ]
Tariq Shaukat: Thank you, Darryl.
That's a fascinating journey that you guys
are on there at HSBC.
Just a couple of questions for you.
You'd mentioned that you did a pretty thorough
investigation of the technologies, particularly
as you were looking at us, around DataFlow
and BigQuery.
What aspects convinced you to move forward
with GCP?
Darryl West: Yeah.
We've -- we spent a good amount of time working
with all the big cloud providers and evaluating
their products.
I think if you look at the scarce talent we
have on data analysts and data scientists,
they need tools that allow them to do their
work in a very productive way, so they've
-- we've found as we've worked with your team
and your subject matter experts working with
our data scientists, that your suite of products
have been very performant, very easy to use.
You know, there's always a challenge of getting
data scientists to shift from their favorite
platform to a new one and I think the way
that your products are actually being configured
and presented to our scientists, they've really
enjoyed that experience.
So, you know, it's early in our relationship.
We're still in pilot mode and we hope to get
these use cases to production in the coming
weeks and months, but I think our experience
so far has been very positive.
Tariq Shaukat: Terrific.
What is -- just looking forward the next three
to five years, how do you see the cloud really
playing out and all these technologies impacting
your business?
Darryl West: Yeah.
Look, it's very difficult to be able to predict
the future, even three years ahead.
That's a long way away, right?
So the world's going to change.
I think what's definitely going to be consistent
is that our data is going to continue to grow.
Massive data sets need to be managed.
We know also we're going to be pushed to go
faster.
I mean, our customer base is dragging us into
a new world and consuming, you know, services
on new digital channels which will require
us to be agile and fast to market.
We know we're going to have the need to use
data analytics, and particularly machine learning,
to run a better business.
So it's going to get bigger, it's going to
get more complex, and we're going to need
to partner with people like Google and others
to be able to use the best technology in the
world to solve these problems for our business.
Tariq Shaukat: Great.
Well, finally, I think everyone in the audience,
I'm sure, could use a little advice.
You guys are leaning very forward into the
cloud and cloud technology.
What advice would you give everyone here for
how to really start their journey?
Darryl West: Yeah.
Well, I think the first thing you need to
do is you have to make the jump in thinking
to make yourself a cloud-first company.
It requires, you know, getting everybody on
board in the technology team but also the
business.
You've got to get the business to think about
things in a very different way.
And I mentioned the criticality of new ways
of working with agile methods, devops methods
is really important.
But the first thing is, make that jump and
be bold and have courage to go and do the
innovative things.
Second thing is, pick a partner that has the
same type of culture as you.
I think you need to -- if you're going to
be innovative, you're going to be bold and
take on big challenges, you need a partner
that's going to think the same way and work
in the same ways of working.
And just I think basically the conclusion
I've come to is have a good look out there,
meet, you know, the people in the market,
because they're all very different, and certainly
from my perspective the chemistry between
the people and the teams is actually the number
one -- the number one thing, because what
we're doing is complex and what we're doing
is difficult in many cases, and the chemistry
and the culture of the organizations is very
important and that's --
Tariq Shaukat: And it's a multiyear journey.
Darryl West: And it's a multiyear journey
so you have to like who you're hanging out
with for the years ahead.
Tariq Shaukat: Exactly.
Well, again, on behalf of all of Google Cloud,
we're really thrilled that you're here today,
so thank you very much.
Darryl West: Thank you.
Tariq Shaukat: And I'd like to welcome Diane
Greene back onto the stage.
[ Applause ]
Diane Greene: Thank you, Tariq and Darryl.
That was fantastic.
And now, we're going to have a look at how
an iconic eCommerce company, eBay, is thinking
about the cloud.
I think we have a video first, and I want
to welcome on stage RJ Pittman, who is head
of products, CTO --
Speaker: eBay is all over the world.
We transfer about 30 gigs a second and search
through 1 billion active listings in our quest
to find your "perfect."
Through cutting-edge technology and the performance
and scale of cloud, we strive to meet our
customers where they are and transform the
future of commerce to help find your version
of "perfect."
The future of commerce from eBay.
Diane Greene: Cool.
[ Applause ]
Diane Greene: RJ, thank you for coming.
Great to have you here.
RJ Pittman: Great to see you.
Diane Greene: So RJ, you've had a phenomenal
amount of experience working in online environments.
Why don't you start talking about how your
view of the cloud has changed.
RJ Pittman: Well, the biggest thing is, it's
moving and it's moving fast.
In the last four years, it's, from my perspective,
gone from a very powerful and compelling proposition
for outsourcing your I.T.
infrastructure and shifting some things so
that you can focus on your core business to
now we see it as a strategic growth engine
and a strategic growth engine that accelerates
innovation.
And this is a very different position that
the cloud has taken and it's playing a very
important role for us in that manner at eBay.
Diane Greene: And what do you think that means
for eBay?
RJ Pittman: Well, you know, so in the video,
as you can see, I mean, we've been around
for a long time.
The business is continuing to grow.
We have over 1 billion live listings at any
given moment in 200 countries around the world
--
Diane Greene: Yeah.
RJ Pittman: -- 167 million shoppers, and so
you can imagine that if we start moving the
capabilities of the cloud to eBay, we're not
just changing our infrastructure and changing
our business.
We're changing the experience for all of those
shoppers and all of our buyers and sellers
around the world.
And that's the really important connective
tissue here.
This is not just a technology exercise for
us.
It is absolutely a customer-centric effort.
Diane Greene: Yeah.
Absolutely.
And, you know, with that kind of phenomenal
growth, I can see that you really are paying
attention to technology to help you through
it.
Yeah.
RJ Pittman: Yeah.
It's -- you know, for us, the eCommerce space
is competitive and it's moving fast and the
demands of customers and shoppers today is
changing so quickly, and as new generations
of buyers come into the world, first mentales,
now Gen Zers, they have very different shopping
habits, very different expectations, and they're
much higher expectations.
And so we, eBay, at our scale, if we're, you
know, intent on setting ourselves up to meet
the demands and exceed the demands of this
next generation of online shoppers, we have
to move quickly and the cloud has become a
very strategic partner for us in that.
Diane Greene: So RJ, before we get into our
cool demo, can you just tell me a little bit
about what you're doing on Google Cloud?
RJ Pittman: Sure.
So this was an undertaking for us that we've
been thinking about for a few years, but we
really got serious about it a year ago, and
we knew that there was a lot of untapped potential
inside the eBay marketplace and we wanted
to get at it.
And as a marketplace, let's also remember
that first and foremost we're a tech company
and we utilize technology to differentiate,
to compete, to innovate, and to create these
amazing customer experiences for all of our
customers around the world.
And so for us, we went out on a mission and
said, "If we could bring the eBay marketplace
to a modern stack environment, if we could
bring our customers to a place with we can
be innovating almost every day and bringing
great new features and capabilities to them,
you know, that would give us a tremendous
advantage and a ton of momentum."
So literally in the space of about five months,
we took a great team of engineers and set
off to do exactly that, and in five months
we went from nothing to the entire 1 billion
live listings of eBay running in GCP.
It was not a test.
It was not a prototype.
It quickly moved to a production-grade environment
for us that we ended up launching and bringing
into market six months ahead of our plan,
and mind you, that in total, start to finish,
was about seven months.
So it can be done.
Diane Greene: Yes.
RJ Pittman: Do not fear the cloud.
It can be done.
And look, in our business, this is super important.
You can't -- you have to be careful when you're
serving live customers in a live marketplace
like that.
And now the way we -- we've approached it,
we were smart about this and we didn't just
flip the switch and, you know, move the entire
$85 billion marketplace business at the throw
of a switch.
We're actually running a parallel swim lane
and that gives us lots of latitude to play
with.
And they're both live systems.
And this is very difficult to do in any -- in
most environments because we're transacting,
as you saw, thousands of orders a second,
and we now have two hot/hot systems running.
Our core system on-prem and then we have the
new Google platform both serving customers.
And we've had to build a system that ensured
that we didn't create two separate marketplaces.
Meaning no two buyers could buy the same one
item that's for sale because that would create,
obviously, a lot of problems for us.
And it was actually one of the most important
decision factors for us in really leaning
in on the Google platform is the services
and the capability that Google Offers that
nobody else did that allowed us to build a
true replication -- replicated system that
runs in real time side by side to help companies
of our size and scale and complexity make
that transition much more seamlessly to the
cloud.
Now, mind you, the other cool thing about
it is it didn't just allow us to go to a cloud
instance here in North America, but using
the global footprint of GCP, we took the show
on the road and we were able to test our theory
and look at lighting up the Google Cloud in
multiple countries around the world, so that
we could be serving where our customers are
and providing a great high-speed performance
as if that data center was sitting in their
backyard.
We've not been able to offer that kind of
experience and that kind of performance in
the 22 years, you know, that we've been around,
so this is really breakthrough for us, and
it's our customers that are the ones that
really stand to gain.
Diane Greene: That's just a great story of
what you have done.
I think in another area you have leveraged
AI for your catalog.
What about that?
RJ Pitman: This is a really cool part of the
story where we have a billion live listings,
and we have 22 years of historical transaction
data.
We have more economic data on the supply and
demand information on virtually any product
that has been made and sold in the last 20
years.
We know what it sold for, what the demand
was, what countries, you know, are most interested,
and what products and when.
You can imagine if we could then start to
encapsulate and capture all of that knowledge
and bring it forward for our shoppers, you
could build arguably one of the smartest shopping
experiences and smartest catalogs on the planet.
And the challenge there, too, has been getting
to a place where we had truly the computing
capacity and performance to get our arms around
literally billions and billions of records
that go back in time but also the new ones
that are created every day that there's transactions
on eBay.
And going to GCP, we have the scale and the
performance that allowed us to lay down some
really great AI technology going well beyond
machine learning and going very seriously
into deep learning, natural language understanding
and computer vision to create something that
we called eBay ShopBot.
And this thing is pretty great.
And it is the largest marketplace in social
where we took our billion-item catalog and
merged it with a billion people in the social
graph and brought them a highly personalized
shopping assistant that gets to know you,
that understands natural language, and can
start to make really, really great recommendations
across our entire inventory of a billion items
to give you -- help you find the best item
for you at the right time at the right place
at the right price.
And so when technology can start doing the
heavy lifting and provide you with almost
a concierge-like personalized service, I think
that's when we've really, really made great
strides.
That's something that we brought together
with the innovation at eBay and the great
work going on in Google.
Diane Greene: I have to say that sounds like
a perfect match for Google Home.
And we actually have a Google Home sitting
over there.
Could you show us all what you're talking
about?
RJ Pitman: In the spirit of going to where
our customers are, we've taken it to Google
Home because we want to get inside the home.
Let's do it.
Diane Greene: Now, you know, we're doing this
live.
There's, like, 10,000 people on the network.
We really hope this works.
[ Laughter ]
RJ Pitman: Hey, Google.
Let me talk to eBay.
Google: Sure.
Here's eBay.
Speaker: Hi, I'm eBay.
I'm the world's price guide.
You can ask me what something is worth.
RJ Pitman: What's my camera worth?
Speaker: Is it new or used?
RJ Pitman: New.
Speaker: What is the brand of your camera?
RJ Pitman: Canon.
Speaker: Tell me the model of your new Canon
camera.
RJ Pitman: 5D.
Speaker: What else do you want to tell me
about your Canon camera?
RJ Pitman: Nothing.
Speaker: Your camera is worth $2,548.
RJ Pitman: Not bad.
[ Applause ]
So this is, you know, maybe an unexpected
use case but one that's really interesting
and close to the hearts of eBay because we
support not only our shoppers but also our
tens of millions of sellers all around the
world.
And what this allows us to do is start to
bring more sellers into the marketplace.
You may have lots of really cool things sitting
around your house that you didn't know had
really great market value.
Now you will be able to ask Google and ask
eBay through the Google Home partnership to
get you started and bring you a little bit
closer to eBay.
And there's so much more to come with this
technology.
Diane Greene: Absolutely.
RJ Pitman: Let me tell you this.
It was five months for us to go from where
we were to in the Google Cloud.
And it took us five days to get into Google
Home.
So, you know, with that kind of power, there's
great, great potential.
[ Applause ]
Diane Greene: RJ, thank you so much.
RJ Pitman: Thank you.
Thank you.
Diane Greene: That was fantastic.
RJ Pitman: Really fun being here.
Thanks, everyone.
Diane Greene: I just love the fat that here's
a chat bot running on Google Cloud talking
to Google Home.
We have One Google partnering with eBay.
And now you're all in for a treat.
We're going to bring Fei Fei Li on stage.
I first met Fei Fei when she came to Stanford
back in 2012.
She's a neighbor of mine.
And for those of you that don't know, Fei
Fei was really instrumental in the explosion
of machine learning.
She built ImageNet, which is the largest database
of labeled images.
And what that facilitated was all the academic
researchers, industry researchers now had
something to benchmark against.
And we started seeing this explosive improvement
and adoption of machine learning.
So let me just welcome to the stage Fei Fei
Li.
She is in charge of Google's cloud machine
learning.
She's had of the AI lab at Stanford and here
now to lead us in our AI efforts at Google.
Please welcome.
[ Applause ]
Fei Fei Li: Good morning, everyone.
My name is Fei Fei Li.
I'm the chief scientist of Google Cloud AI
and machine learning.
So in Google's code word, I'm still a Noogler.
And it's quite an honor and privilege to be
on this stage to share with you some of my
thoughts about AI, machine learning, and Google
Cloud.
So the world is changing incredibly fast.
Some say that we're living in the fourth Industrial
Revolution.
And many of it is propelled by the phenomenal
force of computing.
As an AI technologist for nearly 20 years
working on machine learning, computer vision,
I've witnessed my field growing from a lofty
but academic pursuit to the biggest driver
of this change.
But change happens at many scales, and it
takes imagination to see them all.
Let's take a familiar example, the self-driving
car.
It's easy to understand the appeal.
With the help of sensors and algorithms, a
self-driving car reduces accident risks and
gives us more time to work, socialize, and
just relax while commuting.
This is great for a single driver.
But what happens when thousands of people
have self-driving cars?
Suddenly, through the coordination of vehicles,
traffic congestion is reduced and parking
is dramatically simplified.
And what about millions of people having them?
Entire cities will be reshaped by -- to reflect
the fundamental shift in the use of its infrastructure.
So the difference between each scale is participation.
As a technology reaches more people, its impact
becomes more profound.
This is why the next step for AI must be democratization,
lowering the barriers to entry and making
it available to the largest possible community
of developers, users, and enterprises.
Speaking of democratization and reaching many
people, Google Cloud Platform already delivers
our customers' applications to over a billion
users every day.
That's a lot of participation.
Now, if you can only imagine combining the
massive reach of this platform with the power
of AI, making it available to everyone, then
we stand to witness a greater improvement
in quality of life than any other time in
history, from finance to education, from manufacturing
to healthcare, from retail to agriculture.
You name it.
This is why delivering AI and machine learning
through Google Cloud excites me.
It means finally sharing the technology and
insights I've been involved in for years as
an AI researcher at Stanford.
That's also where, by the way, I began a collaboration
and partnership in AI with Dr. Jia Li who
was one of my first Ph.D. students many years
ago.
I'm very excited that she has joined Google
with me as the head of R&D in AI and machine
learning at cloud.
And speaking of International Women's Day
today, this is another bad ass woman in STEM,
CS, and AI.
[ Applause ]
There's no shortage of examples of AI solving
real-world problems, such as the demo we just
saw that eBay -- talking to the eBay ShopBot
through Google Home.
As impressive as these achievements are, they're
just the beginning of the transformation of
the entire enterprise.
More and more problems are being addressed
by AI, and the tools we use to build AI solutions
are becoming more and more sophisticated in
their functions but also easier to use.
This will change our world dramatically, and
it's happening at a faster pace than most
people think.
Let's take a look at a few examples.
AI has been influencing retail as long as
it's existed.
For instance, machine learning algorithms
are already helping Google's AdSense and shopping
to deliver relevant information to our customers.
But so much more is just waiting to be done,
such as supply chain optimization for routes
and inventory or predicting changes in demand
over time, drone navigation and self-driving
vehicles for delivery of items customers ordered,
intelligent analysis for loss prevention and
safety, or understanding customer movements
and perception in stores, to optimize shelf
space, displays, and visibility.
Another example for media and culture already
being influenced by AI.
Do you have a teenager at home?
Wonder why -- what's the technology that's
mesmerizing them with the cat-ear and rainbow
filters of the Snapchat app?
That's a clever computer vision technology.
Machine learning already delivers Google Photo
automatic image tagging and YouTube's recommendation
list.
But media experiences will soon make much
more use of it.
AR and VR will rely on computer vision for
motion tracking, environment detection, and
games.
More and more news content will be automatically
generated allowing journalists to focus on
bigger and deeper stories.
And AI will play a growing role in helping
us to create and stylize our own content such
as videos, music, and artwork.
In the financial services world, we're already
seeing machine learning to help fairly and
intelligently predict credit card risk for
new applicants or even anticipate delinquencies
among existing customers.
And many similar advances are in the work
as we speak.
Insurance claims will be assessed by machine
learning agents.
Banking will become even more virtual as conversation
bots take over for call centers or even in-person
bankers when managing finances.
And as HSBC said earlier, our own perception
will be augmented with intelligent agents
to flag criminal activity such as money laundering
or fraud.
Last, but not least, example here, healthcare
is among the most profound applications of
AI for truly improving people's lives.
We've already seen some incredible AI achievements
in recent years.
A few months ago my colleagues at Google Brain
has shown that using a deep-learning algorithm,
a computer can detect signs of diabetic retinopathy,
a disease that can potentially blind more
than 400 million people.
Now, imagine that kind of insight spanning
the entire healthcare industry.
So many forms of visual diagnosis may soon
be automated to help doctors and reduce overhead
and errors and extending treatment to the
underserved population.
Machines can also help to handle clerical
tasks such as scribing doctor visits, managing
chronic diseases, leading to more reliable
and faster services.
And this will culminate into full-scale smart
hospitals and homes with intelligent sensors
to track hospital activity, keep patients
safe, ensure adherence to hygiene practices,
and augment surgical protocols.
I hope you're excited, just as I am, about
the opportunities that AI and machine learning
can deliver.
But this remains a field of high barriers.
It requires rare expertise and resources few
companies can afford on their own.
That's why cloud is the ideal platform for
AI.
That's also why we're making huge investment
in cloud AI/ML that will emerge over the next
year in the form of powerful, easy-to-use
tools that will give every cloud customer
an on-ramp into this field.
In other words, Google Cloud is democratizing
AI.
This entails four broad steps: Democratizing
computing, democratizing algorithms, democratizing
data, and democratizing talent and expertise.
And let's talk about each -- what each of
these means.
First and foremost, AI requires enormous computing.
Today a deep-learning algorithm can easily
boast tens of millions of parameters and billions
of connections.
Training and using such models require computational
resource.
Of course, that's exactly what the cloud was
designed to deliver.
Last year, we introduced the beta version
of Cloud ML Engine.
Today I'm here to announce its general availability.
Cloud ML Engine is a platform that can harness
all the power, computing power, and deliver
it to you transparently.
Simply put, you develop the machine learning
models however you like using familiar tools
like the TensorFlow library in your own environment.
ML Engine allows you to focus on the creativity
of your solution and leave the infrastructure
to us, then when it's time to train those
models upload them to the cloud where ML Engine
can do it much faster and at a much larger
scale.
Finally, deploy the result anywhere from your
own premises to a mobile device where it can
put its training to use to solve real-world
problems.
But even with the compute power in the world,
AI remains among the most complex field in
computer science.
And that's still a serious obstacle for many
enterprises and customers.
For developers not quite ready to build their
own models, the easiest way to put AI to use
today is through one of the APIs Google has
provided to deliver fully trained machine
learning models to tackle common problems.
These APIAPIs are like a switch that immediately
activate an intelligent component in any application,
allowing it to understand speech and photos
or translate text or parse natural language.
But there's a lot more to Google's depth and
breadth of AI technology.
At Google, we have numerous research teams
housing an enormous amount of ongoing AI research
spanning many areas of AI and machine learning.
Our researchers are some of the most prolific
authors of scientific papers at top AI journals
and conferences, and our teams are frequent
winners of best papers and AI competitions.
And the results of this work are quickly turned
into products and services that we want to
deliver to our customers.
So I'm especially eager to announce some of
the latest products of that effort.
The vision API has been under steady development
and features some significant new capabilities.
First is an expansion of the API's metadata
to recognize millions of entities from Google's
Knowledge Graph for images that are available
on the Web.
We're now using the same metadata that powers
the entire Google Image Search.
Second, an enhanced optical character recognition,
capable of retrieving text from images of
text-heavy documents such as legal contracts
and other complex paperwork.
But the world of pixels goes beyond just pictures.
In fact, videos are among the most prevalent
form of Internet data.
YouTube alone sees hundreds of hours of videos
uploaded every minute.
Understanding the rich content of videos has
been a tremendous technology challenge for
many years.
In fact, many of us computer vision researchers,
we've often considered videos the dark matter
of the digital universe.
Today, I'm very excited to announce an entirely
new API powered by machine intelligence: The
video intelligence API.
I'd like to introduce my colleague, Sara Robinson,
to demonstrate this API in more details.
Sara?
Sara Robinson: Thank you, Fei Fei.
[ Applause ]
Sara Robinson: Thank you.
So the best way to experience the video API
is through a live demo and let's start by
taking this video of a Super Bowl commercial
for Google Home and I'm going to play the
first few seconds.
We can see that it starts with a mountain
landscape and we see a house, a city street,
then it goes to a dog in a garage.
So lots of scene changes happening in this
video.
And if we were to manually categorize what
was happening throughout it, we'd need to
watch the entire thing and write down what
was happening in every scene.
Luckily, the video API takes care of this
for us, which is a single REST API request.
So it tells us two things.
One, at a high level it tells us what is this
video about, and then it also tells us at
a more granular level what labels it finds
in the video in each scene.
So if we scroll down here, we can see it identifies
a dog and it can tell us exactly where in
the video that dog appears.
It also identifies at the end of the video,
there's a birthday cake.
And if we scroll down a bit more, we can see
that not only does it know it's a dog, it
knows what type of dog it is, that it's a
dachshund.
And if we scroll down through the rest of
the labels, we can see that it also successfully
identifies that mountain pass scene from the
beginning.
So this is what the API can do with one video,
but you likely have more than one video that
you want to analyze.
So let's take a look at how a company might
use the video intelligence API.
A media publisher could have hundreds of petabytes
of video data sitting in storage buckets and
one common thing they might want to do is
create a highlight reel focused on a specific
type of content or search their large library
for a specific entity.
So let's see how we would use the video intelligence
API to search a large library of videos, given
all this metadata that we get back from it.
So we've got a lot of videos here and let's
say this media publisher has hours of sports
video but they only want to find the content
relative to baseball.
So let's go ahead and search our library here
for baseball videos.
And we can see that not only does it show
us which videos have baseball, it tells us
exactly when in those videos baseball appears.
My favorite example is this one.
We have this video which only has a tiny bit
about baseball but it's able to identify that
clip for us, whereas if we were to manually
do this, we'd have to watch the whole video,
looking for that specific scene.
So if we click on this scene, we can see that
this is from last year's year-end search video
when the Cubs won the World Series.
So let's do one more search.
I live on the East Coast where it's pretty
cold right now.
I've heard there's been a ton of rain in SF
this past year.
I think we can all agree it would be pretty
nice to be on a beach right now.
And while machine learning can't take us there,
it can do the next best thing and find all
the beach clips in our video library for us.
So let's search for our beach videos, and
then we can click to all of our beach clips
in the videos below.
So as you saw through this demo, the video
intelligence API makes it easy to quickly
and easily understand a large library of video
content, something that was almost impossible
just a few months ago.
Tasks that used to take hours now takes seconds
with the video intelligence API and I'm excited
to make it available to all of you today.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Sara Robinson: And back to Fei Fei.
Fei Fei Li: Thank you.
Thank you, Sara.
So I'm so excited to see this.
As a computer vision researcher, I've seen
my field working on video understanding for
decades, and now finally we're beginning to
shine light onto the dark matter of the digital
universe and provide values to our customers
who can use it to harness the enormous amount
of information embedded in these videos.
Now, let's go on.
Data is the next piece of the democratization
puzzle.
Just as we learn through a lifetime of exposure
to the world to gain our human intelligence,
AI requires a huge amount of data to develop
its own insight.
But these data sets are among the steepest
barriers to overcome.
I have a lot of personal experience of this,
having led the development of the ImageNet
data set, which provides over 15 million labeled
images to the machine vision community.
Many of you are now familiar with the history
after ImageNet.
In 2012, it became one of the most important
enablers of the deep learning revolution.
But to this day, it's still one of the most
used training data sets and benchmarks of
deep learning algorithms.
While the results of ImageNet have been incredible,
the long, difficult journey of putting it
together was a tremendous testament of how
great the challenge still remains.
What we need is a more scalable and effective
way to democratize data to more data scientists,
machine learning developers, domain experts,
and eventually to our business.
That's why I'm thrilled to make the next announcement,
Google Cloud's acquisition of Kaggle.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Fei Fei Li: For years, led by cofounders Anthony
Goldbloom and Ben Hamner, the Kaggle team
has been building an unprecedented community
of over 850,000 data scientists, hosting contests,
and making new data sets publicly available.
By merging with Google Cloud Platform, we're
giving this community direct access to the
most advanced machine learning environment,
as well as providing a direct path to market
their models.
Working together with Kaggle, we're empowering
the largest concentration of machine learning
talent in the world.
In fact, Kaggle is already partnering with
Google Cloud and research to host the largest
video understanding competition called the
YouTube-8 Million Video Understanding Challenge.
So speaking of talent and expertise, we've
also been extremely committed to help our
partners and customers to develop more machine
learning and AI expertise at the levels they
need.
At Google, we've always made significant investments
in research.
Every year, Google gives large grants to over
250 academic research projects worldwide,
supports dozens of Ph.D. students, and hosts
thousands of interns.
Moreover, the Google Brain Residency Program
recognizes that expertise in AI will be an
increasingly important resource in years ahead
and is taking steps to find, educate, and
empower the future leaders of this field.
At Google Cloud, in parallel with all these
efforts, we're equally committed to using
our expertise to deliver real results right
now to our customers.
The Advanced Solutions Lab allows customers
with more ambitious goals to partner directly
with Google to solve complex AI problems.
Let's take the insurance company USAA as a
recent example.
Many of their engineers were well-versed in
data science, and some even had a background
in machine learning, but they needed help
to build a true foundation of expertise.
To do this, a team of USAA developers came
to Google's Advanced Solutions Lab where they
learned directly from our own machine learning
engineers and experts.
That team now is hard at work putting their
new skills to use, with additional teams being
trained in the same way.
So I think the most meaningful technologies
are the ones that transform a precious resource
into something that can benefit everyone.
The printing press helped literacy expand
beyond the privileged, made books so affordable
that they could fill the shelves in homes
and libraries all over the world.
The electric grid delivered power to entire
communities, turning heat and light from luxuries
to staples of everyday life.
The mass production of the Industrial Revolution
meant that artisanal objects that were once
prohibitively expensive could now enrich the
lives of hundreds and millions of people.
And of course the Internet has made everything
from newspaper to university courses so easy
to share that they can reach a worldwide audience
overnight, often for free.
What these examples have in common is the
transformation from exclusivity to ubiquity.
I believe AI can deliver this transformation
at a scale we've never seen and imagined before,
to help spread the luxuries of the privileged
few to the rest of us at a global scale.
This is why I'm inviting everyone in this
audience to be part of this.
We at Google Cloud are making the tools available,
but it's up to you to put them to use.
And speaking of AI, it took a few years to
convince our next speaker of the power, the
sweeping power, of AI.
So if you're still on this journey, it's really
not a shame because you're in very good company.
It's my honor and privilege to invite Mr.
Eric Schmidt.
[ Applause ]
Eric Schmidt: Thank you very much, Fei Fei.
Fei Fei Li: Good luck.
Eric Schmidt: Thank you.
Fei Fei said, "Leave the infrastructure to
us," and I don't think anyone could have said
it better.
Last year when I was here, I said, "We will
-- we will meet you where you are."
What I've thought about this year is, "Just
get to the cloud now.
Just -- just go there now.
There's no time to waste anymore."
There's lots of reasons and I think we've
talked about them this morning, but imagine
a model that goes something like this: You're
sitting there and you are building something
on a container on your laptop.
You get it working and then you just release
it to the cloud and it scales infinitely.
That's how easy this is now.
That's how easy it is for you to do this as
an individual programmer.
Now, does this matter?
Well, it mattered in the last year.
Let's think about Pokemon Go, right?
So here's a fantastic product which had 50
times more demand in its first two hours than
ever planned in their most optimistic forecasts.
And I'm pleased to say that our system expanded
-- right?
-- that the container architecture and the
use of Kubernetes actually could handle the
load.
And I'm quite convinced there was no other
way to handle such a global phenomenon.
And you sit there and you go, "Well, I'm not
trying to be Pokemon Go."
Well, if you could, you'd be pretty happy.
[ Laughter ]
Eric Schmidt: Think about the sort of global
success.
So you might as well plan for global success
and infinite demand.
And even if you don't hit it, your architecture
will be right and your costs will be lower.
I'll give you another example.
Start -- well, if it sounds like open source
-- right?
-- using Kubernetes, Apache Beam, Spinnaker,
using GRPC, Redis, HBASE, you're going to
have a blast.
It's going to be a great week, right?
Give you another example consistent with this.
We just had the strongest IPO in a long time
in tech in Snap and Snapchat.
As part of that, when you read the narrative,
there are two things that strike you.
First was their incredibly fast software development
in their app, both on Android and iPhone,
and in their community, with huge success,
new models, new models of interaction which
you all know and many of you use.
But the other confusion that's interesting
in their process was nobody could figure out
how they could do this with so little capital.
And the answer is because they used our infrastructure
-- right?
-- in a deal that's a hugely successful deal
for both corporations.
So you sit there and you go, "Well, why would
they do that?
I mean, after all, had they spent $2 billion
in data centers, they'd have $2 billion worth
of data centers."
Yeah, but then they'd be putting 3 billion
and 4 billion and 5 billion and 6 billion
in, whereas this way we can ride the scale
and the investment that we have done.
So are you not planning to be like Snapchat?
Well, I think everyone here who represents
a corporation would be -- would be happy to
be as successful as they are.
Makes sense, right?
But the interesting insight is in the last
year, we've done two things since this conference
that I'm particularly proud of.
One Fei Fei talked about, which is the sort
of making machine learning real at a commercial-
and enterprise-grade scale.
You saw the demos, you understand the message.
I'll talk about that in a minute.
But the other thing that we did is we took
the Google network, which is vastly better
than anything else you've ever seen, all that
dark fiber, all that special fiber, all that
interconnect, and we made it directly accessible
to the programs that you're using.
So using Snap as an example, not only can
they use our platform infrastructure, but
they get access to their global customers
through our network by virtue of the way this
works.
That's a very big deal.
So you say, "Well, I'm only trying to get
regional customers."
Dream big.
Think about having customers in pretty much
every country.
You get the idea.
So what I want you to do is I want you to
sort of understand that we can do both great
cloud -- that is, great technology in the
cloud -- but we can also now work with you
as a customer and a partner to build a business
that actually scales globally in which you
make a lot of money, which is ultimately what
everybody cares about.
So I want you to imagine that --
And the good news is -- and Fei Fei talked
about, and the others have talked about it
as well -- we have this incredible leadership
platform for the things that I think matter
for the future.
But the truth is that most of our customers
are still struggling with the enormous challenge
of their existing infrastructure.
Most customers say, "That's a great speech,
but I'm still trying to deal with my non-X86
apps, my AS/400 mainframe," all the kind of
stuff that they have.
And many of you work in such companies or
run them.
So what -- how do you do that?
So let's imagine a sales call where I am your
salesperson visiting you and we say, "What
are we going to do?"
And what I'll tell you, the first thing to
do is take your x86 binaries that you have
in some data center inside your company and
move them to the Google VM.
And you go, "Huh."
Well, turns out it's cheaper, and if it's
cheaper, that frees up some money to do the
next step.
So the first thing is the easiest one.
Literally take the existing PCs and the existing
PC software -- that is, x86 software specifically
-- and put it onto the Google VM.
What do you do with the existing systems?
You leave them running.
Makes perfect sense.
That's Phase 1.
What do you do next?
What you do is you take that system, now you've
got it working half in the cloud, half not,
and you say, "I'm now carefully going to take
the data out of all these systems and put
it in a modern, scalable, managed database,
either SQL or non-SQL."
How do I do that?
Well, we work with you to do that.
And then of course over time, you build and
move that data to modern end-to-end services.
I'll bet my -- the rest of my professional
career that the future of your business is
big data and machine learning applied to the
business opportunities, customer challenges,
and things before you.
It's true whether it's the video API, an intelligent
service we just announced, or more traditional
classification or the new deep learning approaches
that are being pioneered at Google and elsewhere.
So what happens is, at that point you say,
"Okay, I managed to get the data over here.
Now I don't know what to do."
Well, Google has a lot of resources that we
can throw at this.
We have customer engineers -- right?
-- to help you.
We've got an office of the CTO to help you
with the technology.
We've got solutions architects who actually
do a whole business solution for you.
We have an Advanced Solutions Lab that actually
showcases some of these things.
We have professional services that you can
work with in the ways that you would imagine.
We have people who can -- called strategic
customer engineers who help you build your
cloud.
And we finally have customer reliability engineering
to keep the thing running.
Right?
So not only is it --
It used to be we would say, "Well, we have
this incredible technology derived from the
way Google operates," but we didn't have a
full-service product offering.
We didn't have all the service, we didn't
have all the people to help you.
And you're sitting there going, "Well, do
I really believe you?"
Well, we have the references now.
They are among you and you've heard some of
them today.
And what's interesting is that not only do
you have to do that, but you're going to need
additional help, especially with the legacy
systems, so we have system integrator partners.
So examples that I wrote down, Pythian, Agosto,
Groovenauts, SADA, global systems integrators
like Accenture and PwC.
So okay.
That sounds like a pretty good pitch.
The last time anybody looked at this, it takes
years to make this transition, so that was
another problem that we faced a year ago and
we figured out how to solve that.
We're working now to get these conversions
to occur in one month, two months, three months,
four months.
And why?
Because time is everything.
And you -- while you're doing this conversion,
to some degree some of your customer experience
software, some of your value added is sort
of being held captive.
So another example, we have Lush, which is
a cosmetic retailer, moved their point of
sale in a month.
Ocado rebuilt into the cloud in six hours.
We used all of Evernote with three petabytes
of data in three months.
That's how fast in the model that I'm describing
you can get there.
So I think that there was a speed limit.
That speed limit was defined by our ability
to work with the data that you had and the
install base that you had and moving it into
this new model.
The new model works.
Trust me.
If you're doing a new build, you're clearly
going to do that anyway because you're intelligent.
The problem is you are stuck in between.
You can't get to the new one.
You are still stuck on the old one.
So I don't know.
What are some examples?
If you have a data as an object, we now have
a software mechanism that will take the data
and re- -- which we call by simple transfer
service -- which will basically just move
it into our cloud structure; right?
And just do it all over.
That's how the data gets there so quickly.
You built on containers.
Again, we can support every model of containers.
You're built on Hadoop.
We love -- we love Hadoop in the sense that
it's very similar to the architectures it
was based on, and it's easy to host it inside
of our model or use something even more extensive
like BigQuery.
You like virtual machines.
As I said, just move them straight over.
We've made huge strides in terms of engineering
investment and sales and customer service
investment to scale that.
So how do you do this?
Well, first place, if you leave the infrastructure
to us, we put $30 billion -- and I know because
I approved it, so it's real, right -- into
this platform.
Please do not attempt to duplicate it.
You have better uses of your money.
I would much rather have you take the money
that you have and the talent that you have
and build on top of this platform to provide
that rapid iteration and that rapid extension
in the model that I'm describing.
What's interesting is that we're continuing
to take this stuff and make it stronger.
We just launched Spanner.
And if you don't know what Spanner is, Spanner
is, in my view, a work of art in a computer
science sense.
It's a way of doing SQL, so it's a proper
database.
But it's globally essentially replicated and
globally coherent at a scale of data that
has never been seen before.
And, by the way, we use it -- it's how Google
works.
And, by the way, we released it a week ago
for the cloud.
We have a container builder that does the
same thing.
So if you think about it, your model is something
like this.
BigQuery provides petabyte-scale analysis
on demand.
Big Table provides millions of QPS, global
cloud storage for the actual millions of objects;
right?
Again, the prices are very, very low.
In all of this platform that I'm describing,
"this get to the cloud now" model -- and most
people, by the way, are still in the moving
their x86s into VMs, getting some of the data
out of the VMs, putting them into proper databases;
right?
So you're still in the sort of "getting there"
phase.
Once you have the data, you have an opportunity
for real transformation.
I think that big data is so powerful that
nation states will fight over how much data
matters.
That he who has the data that can do the analytics
and the algorithms that Fei Fei talked about
at the scale that we are talking about will
provide huge nation state benefits in terms
of global companies and benefits for their
citizens and so forth and so on.
But this is all basically because once you
have the data, you have to do one more thing.
You have to change from writing programs to
instead building programs that learn outcomes.
And what machine learning really is, and AI
really is, is it's a change in the way you
program.
And over and over again -- and we've talked
about this at some length already as a company
-- we've seen -- because of vision, right,
we have the possibility of drastically reducing
the number of deaths in automobile accidents
and truck accidents.
A big deal; right?
A huge deal.
And, by the way, accidents in cars are going
up right now in America because distracters
appear -- drivers appear to be distracted
by the very technology that is going into
the cars.
So we've got to solve that problem.
We've got to do it now.
That is happening.
In healthcare, in pathology, radiology, all
of the sort of patient-centered issues, we're
not that different from each other.
And the machine learning and collaborative
learning that's now possible really will produce
amazing healthcare outcomes.
And there's a possibility that the kind of
intelligence that is going to be buildable
on these platforms will really surpass the
kind of insights that the average person in
a business is going to have.
We're seeing over and over again people are
using big data to do customer analysis, pattern-matching
analysis, and customer targeting that really
does produce extra insight.
And that extra insight is worth billions and
billions of dollars in their marketing programs
and knowing it.
So let me finish by saying that we're here
for real.
You're here for real.
This is an incredibly serious mission, something
I've wanted to do since I joined the company
17 years ago.
It's something that I know that the people
you've heard, whenever they started, care
a great deal about it.
The company has both the money, the means,
and the commitment to pull off a new platform
of computation globally for everybody who
needs it.
And something which allows you to be satisfied
that our principles, which are basically about
openness and openness access, really will
allow you both the freedom of choice -- you
won't be locked in -- but also the freedom
to innovate.
When I look at our partners and I look at
the speed with which they can now use their
scarce resources, which are always programmers,
to scale their business solutions, their enterprise
solutions, their customer solutions, their
video solutions, and their marketing solutions,
it just warms my heart.
It's something we've looked at -- we've looked
forward to for decades.
With that, thank you very much.
And I'm going to bring you back to Diane.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Diane Greene: Thank you so much.
Eric is always so wonderful to hear Eric's
brilliant insights and perspectives.
He was one of the original enterprise people
way back when.
So I want to just recap what you heard from
our customers, our partners.
You heard from Disney.
They're doing a full lift and shift to Google
Cloud.
They're using -- they're going after machine
learning.
I like to say bring the magic to the magic.
Our SAP partnership so broad, you heard about
certifying HANA.
You heard about integrating with G Suite,
the machine learning partnership, and also
this very interesting partnership we're doing
for a data custodian to help our customers
solve the difficult issues around compliance,
regulatory, security.
And then you heard from our joint customer
Colgate, a 211-year-old company.
You have to keep reinventing yourself to make
it that long.
And they are transforming themselves today
with G Suite.
And then Verizon moving 150,000 employees
to G Suite.
Again, going after a cultural transformation
and dealing with some really difficult issues
around moving to the cloud in their environment.
Then we had Home Depot, very progressive,
forward-looking retailer looking to technology
to get the advantage, looking to machine learning
to get the advantage, already taking advantage
of Google scale to get them through things
like Black Friday.
Then we had a very interesting look into one
of the world's largest banks, HSBC, about
how they're going to use cloud -- Google Cloud
and the technology and the machine learning
to really streamline their operations and
do things people didn't really realize was
possible.
And then we closed out with eBay.
They definitely see Google Cloud as a technology
that gives them huge competitive advantage.
Very interesting how easily they were able
to run their catalog on our cloud and work
in a hybrid environment.
And then, of course, we saw that wonderful
demo where the chat bot running on Google
Cloud was talking to Google Home, giving answers
about the price of a camera in their catalog.
Just terrific stuff.
I want to also -- you know, where are all
the product announcements?
All the product announcements, we have dozens
of them.
They're tomorrow when you'll hear from our
leaders.
You'll hear from Urs Holzle.
You will hear from Brian Stevens.
You will here from Prabhakar Raghavan about
G Suite.
You will hear from Chet Kapoor, the CEO of
Apigee, telling you all kinds of new products
that we are bringing out and where we're going
and quite a bit of vision.
Then Friday it's about developers through
and through.
It's about open source, start-ups.
And Sam Ramji will lead that up.
Before I wrap, I want to really thank our
partners, our precious partners, all 150 of
them on the floor.
I really look forward to working -- running
into you on the showcase floor.
And, personally, I also want to express my
deep appreciation to all the thousands of
people in Google Cloud.
I mean, you're amazing people.
It's why I'm at Google.
And the hard work you've done over the last
year, you know, and how smart and excellent
your work is, much appreciation.
I want to remind you we're going to take a
break.
But at 12:30, we're going to have two real
Internet giants.
I was a judge in the first Queen Elizabeth
prize for engineering.
I think it's now in its third year.
And Vint Cerf and Marc Andreessen were two
of the winners for inventing the Internet.
Those two haven't skipped a beat.
They're actively leading and defining our
world in technology and as an ongoing basis.
They'll be here for a discussion with Quentin
Hardy.
So with that, I'm really wrapping it up.
It's been a long keynote.
Thank you for staying.
We really appreciate it.
And, hey, everybody, enjoy the show.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]